politics has taken an ugly turn inside
the Texas State Capitol
legislators got into a shoving match on
Memorial Day
the confrontation happened after one
lawmaker said he called immigration
officials about protesters in the
gallery that member a Republican from
Dallas also threatened to shoot a
Democratic colleague he claimed it would
be self-defense
the flare-up concerns a new state law
that effectively bans sanctuary cities
in Texas it gives law enforcement
officers the right to question the
immigration status of anyone they
detained to comply with federal law
david beg no is outside the state
capital in Austin David good morning
Alex good morning there were a lot of
protesters in the State Capitol and they
were loud at one point a Republican
representative claims he saw protester
holding a sign that said I am illegal
and I'm here to stay that representative
then told his colleagues I just called
federal immigration police on those
protesters and that's when things got
ugly decorum was lost in the Texas House
Monday as elected officials started
pushing one another during the final day
of the legislative session I did shove
him around a little bit I pushed him
because he needed to get out there
Democrat Pancho Nevarez and Republican
Matt Rinaldi's dust-up came after
Rinaldi told fellow lawmakers that he
had called immigration officials to
report protesters gathered in the House
chamber he said yeah I call dice and and
then he said f em you say things to
incite people a okay
an estimated 1,000 people were inside
the Capitol Monday protesting the state
law which forces Texas sheriff's to help
enforce federal immigration law the
house business stopped in protesters
were ordered to leave the gallery some
were physically removed by Texas State
Troopers Democrat Ramon Romero jr. these
folks understand that what is going to
happen in the future is exactly what
Matt Rinaldi demonstrated he saw the
crowd and he saw illegals House
Democrats are not only laying the blame
squarely on representative Rinaldi
members say he escalated the situation
there was a threat made from
representative Rinaldi to put a bullet
in one of my colleagues head but on
Facebook Rinaldi said representative
poncho Nevarez threatened my life on the
House floor and representative Ramon
Romero physically assaulted me poncho
told me that he would get me on the way
to my car Rinaldi said he made it clear
I would shoot him in self-defense
what's not true is that I threatened his
life lawmakers families were in the
chamber to celebrate the final session
what they saw many say was an
embarrassment to the state there are
enough of us here to remember a time in
Texas where respect and decorum ruled
the day we reached out to representative
Rinaldi at least seven times in the last
12 hours to request an interview but he
never got back to us Gale Rinaldi now
says he fears for his safety and this
morning he is being protected by Texas
State Troopers all right thank you David